WILDLIFE COMMITTEE TO.
TAKE THE VOTE ON THE.
I GENDER. FIRST ITEM.
TO ENTER.
S. B. FIVE EIGHTEEN EDUARDO
GARCIA BY.
YEAH I GALLAGHER.
A CONSENT ITEM.
BY.
GALLAGHER I FIFTEEN TWO ZERO.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FIVE.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE.
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO.
AND.
SP EIGHT THIRTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
TEN TO FIVE.
YES COLLECTIBLES BILLS GET OUT
TO AND THAT WE WILL ADJOURN.
WATER PARKS WILDLIFE
MEETING OF TUESDAY JUNE TWELFTH
OKAY AT GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
WE'RE GOING TO CONVENE THE JOINT
HEARING OF WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE AND BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE.
ON RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION.
AYE MR AYE CHAIRMAN BLOOM WILL
BE JOINING US SHORTLY AND WE'LL.
PAUSE FOR A MINUTE LET HIM SAY
A FEW WORDS AND WELCOME
EVERYONE.
I AND THEN GET BACK ON THE
AGENDA. I THINK YOU FOR
ATTENDING. WITH MY A CO CHAIR.
MISTER BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BUDGET.
AT THREE.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO FULFILL OUR
PART.
IN THE REVIEW OF INITIATIVE
EIGHTEEN OF SIX WHICH WOULD
AUTHORIZE BOND FUNDS FOR VARIOUS
WATER AND GROUNDWATER PROJECTS.
STEINBERG INITIATIVE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN REQUIRES THE
LEGISLATURE TO HOLD JOINT
HEARINGS ON ANY OUTSIDE
INITIATIVE THAT RECEIVED TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT.
OF THE SIGNATURES REQUIRED TO
QUALIFY FOR THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
I KNOW WE ALL WE'RE HERE ARE
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO LISTENING
TO THE DISCUSSION ON S. B. FIVE
WHICH MET WITH VOTER APPROVAL
AS.
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT ON THE
BALLOT LAST TUESDAY.
IN YOUR PACKET WE HAVE SOME
COMPARISONS OF THE BOND AS WELL
AS SOME QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THE INITIATIVE. AT
BEFORE US
A ROLL TODAY'S THE HIGHLIGHT
ISSUES ASK QUESTIONS AND GAIN A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE BOND
WE WILL NOT BE TAKING A VOTE. ON
THE INITIATIVE
TODAY WE WILL FIRST YEAR FROM
MAJOR ALORS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THEY HAVE THE TASK OF PROVIDING
THE PUBLIC WITH AN IMPARTIAL
HOUSES OF THE SPAWN.
TO THAT END WE THANK HER FOR HER
WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
REPRESENTATION. FOLLOWING THE
ALLEY O. PRESENTATION WE WILL
HEAR FROM BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO THE BOND. WE ASK
IF ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS COULD
LIMIT THE TESTIMONY TO FIVE
MINUTES.
WE WILL FOLLOW WITH QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS FROM BOTH
COMMITTEES UP PLEASE HELP ME
WELCOME DOLLARS BUT.
BEFORE SHE BEGINS OF MISTER
BLOOM AND.
COMMENTED LIKE TO MAKE.
GOOD MORNING SORRY FOR BEING A
FEW MINUTES LATE LET'S GET TO
IT.
THE SELLERS I WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING TEARS A MEMBERS
RACHEL EHLERS WITH ALLEGE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SIDE OF THE
SERGEANTS PASSING A HAND OUT
FROM WHICH I'LL SPEAK AT THE
HAND IT SHOULD ALSO BE ON OUR
WEBSITE. AND I BELIEVE ON THAT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL FOR
THOSE FOLLOWING LONG THE PUBLIC.
SO AS AS THE CHAIRMANSHIP I'LL
JUST GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
DESCRIBING THE PROPOSITION AND
IT'S FISCAL EFFECTS ON STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
SO STARTING ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT JUST AN OVERVIEW OF
WHAT OUR ROLE IS IN THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS IT'S TWO FOLD
FIRST BEFORE WHEN INITIATIVE
THEIR FIRST.
SUBMITTED BY STATE LAW REQUIRES
THAT WE PREPARE AN IMPARTIAL
FISCAL ANALYSIS OF EACH
INITIATIVE TO GO WHEN IT GOES
OUT FOR SIGNATURES AS WELL AS A
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THE FISCAL
EFFECTS ARE. ON STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SO WHEN YOU'RE
APPROACH OUTSIDE SAFE WAY YOU
CAN ASK THEM IN AND SEE. WHAT WE
HAVE WRITTEN?
DESCRIBING WHAT THEY'RE ASKING
FOR SIGNATURES AYE WE OFTEN
REFER TO THAT AS THE TITLE AND
SUMMARY AND I BELIEVE A COPY OF
THE TITAN SUMMARY FOR THIS.
INITIATIVE IS INCLUDED IN YOUR
MEMBER PACKET FOR THIS HEARING.
THEN SECONDLY IF FOR THOSE
INITIATIVES THAT DUE QUALIFY FOR
THE BALLOT STATE ROTH REQUIRES
OUR OFFICE TO PROVIDE AN
IMPARTIAL ANALYSIS. OF THE
BALLOT PROPOSITION WHAT IT DOES
AND WHAT THE.
I HAVE FISCAL EFFECTS WILL BE
FOR THE VOTERS SO THAT.
.
SOMETIMES LIMON SOMETIMES DOOR
STOP WHERE THE.
BALLOT GUIDE THAT YOU GET IN
THE MAIL AS A VOTER THOSE
CONTAINED THE DESCRIPTIONS THAT
WE. AND PREPARE FOR THE ANALYSIS
SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
PREPARING THOSE MATERIALS RIGHT
NOW FOR THE INITIATIVES THAT
HAVE ALREADY QUALIFIED OR LOOK
TO QUALIFY FOR THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT. LAST I CHECKED I BELIEVE
THEREFORE THAT HAVE QUALIFIED
INCLUDING THIS IN AN ADDITIONAL
NINE THAT ARE IN THE SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION PROCESS FOR
NOVEMBER.
SO. THIS IS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT ROLE FOR OFFICE THAN
WHAT YOU'RE USED TO SEEING US.
COME BEFORE YOU WE WON'T OFFER
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS ANY.
OPINIONS OR SUGGESTIONS FOR
CHANGES WE REALLY ARE HERE.
IN JUST A FACTUAL ROLE WHAT
DOES THE MEASURE DO AND I WHAT
DO WE BELIEVE THAT FISCAL
EFFECTS MAY BE ON THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO THAT WILL
BE AFFECTED BOTH OF MY
PRESENTATION AS WELL AS ANY.
RESPONSES TO QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
ASK.
SO TURNING THE PAGE TWO OF THE
HANDOUT. BECAUSE THIS BOND US
PROVIDE MANY FOR WATER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS JUST A
BRIEF BACKGROUND ON CURRENT
SPENDING. AND FUNDING FOR THOSE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THE VAST
MAJORITY AS A FUNDING FOR WATER
RELATED PROJECTS COMES FROM THE
LOCAL LEVEL ITS LOCAL MONEY FOR
PROJECTS IMPLEMENTED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AND THIS AFFECTS
THINGS LIKE DRINKING WATER SEWER
AND WASTE WATER SYSTEMS FLOOD
CONTROL ALL AGRICULTURAL WATER
THAT RESIDENTS PAY FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THESE SPENDING WHY
WHEN THEY PAY THEIR MONTHLY
BILLS. THE STATE PROVIDE SOME
FUNDING FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS PRIMARILY FROM BOND
FUNDS.
IN THE FORM OF LOANS AND GRANTS
AND THEN THE OTHER CATEGORY OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS BOND WE TERM ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS PROJECTS TO IMPROVE THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT CLEANING
PROTECTING HABITAT.
I IN THE STATE OF PLAY A BIGGER
ROLE TYPICALLY IN FUNDING FOR
THOSE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES OFTEN
FROM BONDS.
COM SO IN RECENT YEARS WE
ESTIMATE THE STATE HAS BEEN
ABOUT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR ON THESE TYPES OF WATER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS THAT'S
ROUGHLY THE BUDGETS FOR THE
STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT DO THOSE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
VOTER PROVIDES ARE A COMMON
SOURCE OF FUNDING FROM THE STATE
FOR THESE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES I
THINK THERE'S A CHART IN EUROPE
IN YOUR BACKGROUND MATERIAL
SINCE TWO THOUSAND. VOTERS HAVE
APPROVED THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN A RESOURCE RELATED
BONDS THAT INCLUDES THE FOUR
BILLION THAT WAS APPROVED BY
VOTERS JUST A WEEK AGO TODAY. IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT AND THE
STATE'S CURRENTLY PAYING ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN DEBT
SERVICE FOR.
THOSE PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BONDS.
SO TURNING TO PAGE THREE OF THE
HAND OUT SOME BACKGROUND ON THIS
PROPOSAL THAT IS BEFORE VOTERS
IN NOVEMBER.
HI THIS IS AN EIGHT POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND EIGHT POINT
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TO BE
SPECIFIC.
WE PROVIDE A TABLE HERE THAT
SUMMARIZES THE ACTIVITIES.
THAT WILL BE FUNDED IN THE BOND
AND SIX BROAD CATEGORIES BUT
THE.
PROPOSITION ITSELF INCLUDES
ABOUT A HUNDRED DISCRETE
CATEGORIES ARE POTS OF FUNDING.
AND THAT FOR HOW THE FUNDS
SHOULD BE USED THOSE INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR PARTICULAR REGIONS
OF THE STATE. FOR SPECIFIC
PROJECTS AND FOR SPECIFIC TYPES
OF ACTIVITIES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN THE FIRST
CATEGORY SHOWN IN THE FIGURE
WATERSHED LANDS THERE ARE ABOUT
FIFTY SUB CATEGORIES OF FUNDING.
SOME OF THEM ARE RELATIVELY%
LARGE THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY FOR SIERRA NEVADA
WATERSHEDS TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE SOLVENCY. AND THEN SOME
SMALLER.
AS WELL INCLUDING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS EACH FOR SEVERAL
INDIVIDUAL RIVER PARKWAY HE'S.
THE SECOND CATEGORY SHOWN HERE
WATER SUPPLY VARIOUS TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES STRIKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER TREATMENT WATER
RECYCLING STORM WATER RUNOFF.
THE THIRD CATEGORY FISH AND
WILDLIFE IS SAM ACTIVITIES TO
IMPROVE HABITATS INCLUDING
PURCHASING WATER FOR WETLANDS
AND AGAIN SUB CATEGORIES FOR
SPECIFIC TYPES OF SPECIES
THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED MILLION TO
HELP RESTORE NATIVE FISH IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION FOR MIGRATORY
BIRD HABITAT.
THE FOURTH CATEGORY DOWN WATER
FACILITY UPGRADES IS ACTUALLY
JUST FOR SPECIFIC PROJECTS THAT
ARE FUNDED IN THAT CATEGORY
THEIR SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE MADERA FRANKLIN
CAN NOW.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
BAY AREA WATER RELIABILITY.
TO HUNDRED MILLION FOR OROVILLE
DAM AND FIVE MILLION FOR THE
NORTH BAY AQUEDUCT SO THAT LARGE
CATEGORIES JUST FOR.
THE NEXT CATEGORY DOWN
GROUNDWATER THE BOOK ABOUT MANY
IS FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT SIGMA PHI WOULD
BE GRANTS FOR LOCAL GROUND WATER
AGENCIES TO IMPLEMENT THEIR.
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS THERE'S
ALSO FUNDING IN THAT CATEGORY
FOR AYE DESALINATION OF GROUND
WATER TO MAKE IT MORE USABLE.
AND THEN THE FINAL CATEGORY
FLOOD PROTECTION VISITS TO FOR
PROJECTS TO REDUCE FLOOD RISK
BUT ALSO. A LANGUAGE BE
SUGGESTING THAT THOSE PROJECTS
SHOULD I PROVIDE OTHER TYPES OF
BENEFITS TO THE ECOSYSTEM AND.
WATER SUPPLY.
SO TURNING TO PAGE FOR A FEW
MORE PROVISIONS.
RELATED TO THIS PROPOSITION.
SOMEWHAT UNIQUE FROM OTHER TYPES
OF RESOURCES BONDS THE THIS
PROPOSITION WOULD CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE ALL FUNDS.
SO THE LEGISLATURE WOULD NOT
APPROPRIATE THESE FUNDS THROUGH
THE ANNUAL BUDGET ACT INSTEAD
DEPARTMENTS WOULD RECEIVE THE
FUNDING WHEN THEY'RE READY TO
SPEND IT.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT THERE WAS A
PORTION OF PROPOSITION ONE FOR
WATER STORAGE TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION THAT WAS CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED BUT THE SYSTEM THIS
IS UNIQUE TO HAVE THE ENTIRE
BOND BE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED.
SO MUCH OTHER BONDS MOST OF THE
FUNDING WOULD BE A DISTRIBUTED
FOR VIA GRANTS TO LOCAL AGENCIES
SOME ON A COMPETITIVE BASIS AND
THEN IN SOME CATEGORIES IT JUST
HAM. THAT PROPOSITION IDENTIFIES
WHICH LOCAL AGENCIES FORGET HOW
MUCH FUNDING.
THERE SOME FUNDING FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO DO SOME STATE LEVEL
PROJECTS BUT THE MAJORITY IS A
LOCAL GRANTS.
FOR SOME OF THE CATEGORIES IN
PARTICULAR THOSE RELATED TO
WATER SUPPLY DRINKING WATER
WASTEWATER TREATMENT THERE ARE
LOCAL MATCH REQUIREMENTS WHICH
IS CONSISTENT WITH SOME OTHER
BONDS.
FOR EVERY DOLLAR OF STATE FUNDS
THAT WOULD BE RECEIVED THE LOCAL
AGENCY WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE A
MATCH ALTHOUGH IT'S THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE WAIVED IN SOME
CASES AS I MENTIONED A MOMENT.
I'M THE FIRST ALSO SIMILAR TO
SOME OF OUR RECENT BONDS
INCLUDING PROPOSITION ONE IN
SIXTY EIGHT THE PROPOSITION HAVE
SEVERAL REQUIREMENTS INTENDED TO
BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. USES THE SAME
DEFINITION OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
AS HAS BEEN USED IN PREVIOUS
BONDS.
SO SOME OF THOSE PROVISIONS ARE
IN CERTAIN CATEGORIES IT
REQUIRES THAT A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF FUNDING BE. ALLOCATED TO
THOSE TYPES OF COMMUNITIES AND
AND.
MANY CASES WAVES THAT LOCAL
MATCH REQUIREMENT IF FOR THOSE
AND COMMUNITIES MEETING OF THAT
INCOME REQUIREMENTS.
SO TUNING TO THE FINAL PAGE ON
THE FISCAL EFFECTS OF THIS BOND
AGAIN WE.
BREAK THIS INTO TWO CATEGORIES
WHAT WE ESTIMATE THE COSTS WILL
BE TO THE STATE. AND THEN WHAT
WE ESTIMATE THAT COSTS ARE
SAVINGS MAY BE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO FOR THE STATE.
I WE ESTIMATE THE COST TO TOTAL
COSTS TO TAXPAYERS TO REPAY THE
BOND WOULD BE SEVENTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION.
THAT'S THE EIGHT POINT NINE FOR
THE PRINCIPAL AND THEN WE
ESTIMATE POINT FOUR BILLION IN
INTEREST OVER FORTY YEARS.
AND WE ESTIMATE THIS WOULD
RESULT IN AVERAGE COST TO THE
GENERAL FUND OF AROUND FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
OVER THE NEXT FORTY YEARS NOW
OBVIOUSLY THERE LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS IN THIS ESTIMATE I'M
RELATED TO HOW LONG IT WOULD
TAKE TO SELL THAT BOND AND USE
THE FUNDS WE ESTIMATE TEN YEARS.
THEN THE REBEKAH IN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY YEAR REPAYMENT.
PLAN AND AND WE ESTIMATE OF
FIVE PERCENT INTEREST RATE TO TO
THE DEGREE THAT THOSE.
FACTORS CHANGE IF THE FUNDS
BONDS ARE SOLD MORE QUICKLY OR
OVER A LONGER PERIOD OR INTEREST
RATES ARE DIFFERENT OBVIOUSLY
THOSE NUMBERS WOULD CHANGE BUT
THAT'S OUR ESTIMATE. AND HAS
BEEN PRETTY STANDARD.
FOR HOW WE HAVE ESTIMATED THAT
AFFECTS A BONDS IN RECENT YEARS.
AND THEN TURNING TO THE LOCAL
COSTS AND SAVINGS AGAIN THIS IS
SOMEWHAT HARD TO ESTIMATE.
IN CASES WHERE THE STATE BONDS
ARE REPLACING LOCAL MONEY IF
IT'S A PROJECT AT A LOCAL AGENCY
WOULD BE UNDERTAKING ANYWAY
USING THEIR LOCAL FUNDS AND
INSTEAD THEY CAN USE STATE
FUNDS.
THAT WOULD RESULT IN SAVINGS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND TO THE DEGREE THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES TAKE ON PROJECTS THEY
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE TAKE ON OR
TAKE ON LARGER PROJECTS AND HAVE
TO PUT IN SOME OF THEIR OWN
FUNDING FOR THAT EITHER THROUGH
THE MATCH REQUIREMENT. OR FROM
ONGOING MAINTENANCE THAN THAT
COULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE OTHERWISE
INCURRED.
THE TYPES OF A BY FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THIS BOND IN THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS WE THINK
PROBABLY IT WILL RESULT IN LOCAL
SAVINGS AND OTHER WORDS THAT
FIRST CATEGORY THAT THIS WILL
FUND PROJECTS THAT LOCALS. WOULD
HAVE UNDERTAKEN OTHERWISE TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF SICK
MY.
TO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF
CLEAN WATER ACT TO MEET THEIR
WATER SUPPLY DEMANDS.
AND SO WE ESTIMATE THIS
PROBABLY WILL RESULT WOULD
RESULT IN SOME LOCAL SAVINGS
PERHAPS UP TO A COUPLE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. ON BASED
ON THOSE CATEGORIES.
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
BEST UP.
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION
I HAVE PURCHASED A ONE SIMPLE
QUESTION ON PAGE FOUR WAYS IS A
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
DISADVANTAGED.
A COMMUNITY IS SO I THOUGHT WHEN
WE NEED THE WATER WE NEED SUCH A
DEGENERATE FOR ANY HAD NO REST
DOES.
IN THAT COMMUNITY WHY.
DO YOU SEPARATE DISADVANTAGED
WHILE ADVANTAGE OF COMMUNITIES.
SO A THOUGH THE WHY BEHIND IT I
THINK WOULD BE OF MORE
APPROPRIATE QUESTION FOR THE
PROPONENTS I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
THIS HAS BEEN A TRADITIONAL
PRACTICE IN RECENT YEARS WITH
BONDS TO TRY AND DIRECT THESE
FUNDING I WITH PRIORITIZATION
FOR CERTAIN COMMUNITIES THAT MAY
NOT HAVE AS MUCH LOCAL FUNDING
TO UNDERTAKE THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THEMSELVES.
EXCEPT WHEN THERE'S A NEED FOR
THE WATER AWAY IMPROVING WHAT
THAT I AM SO SUPPLY. IT SHOULD
APPLY TO ANY COMMUNITY WHETHER.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE COMMUNITY
IT MAY BE IS SO HE SO. NOT QUITE
INTERESTING TO CANADA WHERE I
SET A SPECIFIC.
YEAH I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION OF THE
PROPONENTS WHO DESIGNED THE
INITIATIVE THEY'LL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ALASKA TOM.
SUPPORTERS OF THE.
.
INITIATIVE TO COME FORWARD AND
MISTER MARROW.
IS THE AUTHOR AND DESTINY TO
WITH AQUA.
MORE TO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO US SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT THIS INITIATIVE. I'M
JURY MARROW I AM THE PROPONENT
OF THE INITIATIVE AND A FORMERLY
SERVED AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF THE STATE RESOURCES AGENCY.
ARE ALL ESPECIALLY ON WATER
ISSUES.
WHY ARE WE HERE TODAY BEFORE YOU
ARE WE WE MADE A PRETTY STRONG
EFFORT TO TRY TO INCREASE THE
SIZE OF A SENATE BILL SIXTY
EIGHT SENATE BILL FIVE WHICH
TURNED INTO PROP SIXTY EIGHT?
WE THOUGHT THAT IDEALLY THAT
MEASURE WOULD INCLUDE MORE OF
BENEFITS FOR THE WATER SIDE OF
THINGS HEADED DID INCLUDE SOME
VERY GOOD ONES.
BUT ARE WE FAILED IN THAT EFFORT
I SUPPOSE THE BLAME NEEDS TO GO
TO US ON THAT WE DIDN'T BE
PERHAPS TRY STRONGLY ENOUGH BUT
WE FELT THAT. THE NEED OF TO
CONTINUE THE DEVELOPMENT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES WAS LARGE
ENOUGH THAT WE SHOULD PROCEED IN
THE.
WANT TO MENTION JUST A FEW MAYBE
THE MOST IMPORTANT.
IS THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
ELEMENT WE BELIEVE THAT OF THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WHO DO NOT HAVE A
SAFE DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES.
REPREHENSIBLE AND.
JUST OF SOME OF THAT HAS TO BE
SOLVED LEGISLATURE'S BEEN GREAT
IT CONTINUING TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM BUT THE PROBLEM DOES
CONTINUE WE'VE SOLVED THE
PROBLEM MANY COMMUNITIES BUT WE
HAVE MANY MANY MORE WHO HAVE
NOT.
YET GOTTEN THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER SUPPLY WE HAVE TO HAVE A
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM.
THE WATER IS.
IN THIS MEASURE IS REAL A
SOMETIMES PEOPLE QUESTION THE
THE AMOUNT OF WATER YOU CAN
DEVELOP BY THESE WATER BONDS
WE'VE CALCULATED IT'S ON OUR
CAMPAIGN WEBSITE. THAT WE
BELIEVE THIS MEASURE WILL
DEVELOP ENOUGH WATER FOR THREE
MILLION FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S ONE AND A HALF MILLION
ACRE FEET. PEOPLE USE ABOUT A
HALF AN ACRE FOOT PER FAMILY SO
YOU KNOW MAYBE UPWARDS OF TEN
MILLION PEOPLE CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO CONTINUE TO DEVELOP ITS WATER
RESOURCES. STATE CONTINUES TO
GROW AGRICULTURE HAS DEMANDS WE
HAVE TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
ANOTHER MAJOR CATEGORY THE
ANALYST MENTIONED AS WATERSHED
RESTORATION WE HAVE HAD A
TERRIBLE A SITUATION THEY IN THE
SIERRA NEVADA THE CASCADES AND
MANY OF OUR OTHER WATERSHEDS.
FIRE OF OVER GROWTH OF TREES
CONSUMING WAY MORE WATER THAN
THEY SHOULD AND IT'S NOT EVEN
HEALTHY FOR THE FOREST WE HAVE
TO START PAYING ATTENTION TO OUR
WATERSHEDS ARE WE SIMPLY WON'T
HAVE THE WATER SUPPLY WE'VE COME
TO RELY ON.
SO WE'VE INCLUDED A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
MAJOR WATERSHEDS AND MORE IN
SOME OF THE SMALLER WATERSHEDS.
TRY TO BRING THESE WATERSHEDS
BACK TO THE SOURCE OF OUR WATER
IN OUR WATER QUALITY WE HAVE TO
DRESS THAT.
WITH RESPECT TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY THE PEOPLE WITH
THE WORST WATER SUPPLY ALMOST
ALWAYS ARE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THAT REALLY DOES
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION MR
SETTLEMENT. REGARDING WHY SOME
OF THE MONEY
DOES IT A BIAS IN THE SENSE
TOWARD DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
OF PLACES LIKE EAST BAY MURDER
CENTER CLEAR WATER DISTRICT OR
LADWP HAVE WONDERFUL RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLIES PEOPLE ENJOY
THEM.
BUT WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE THAT AND SO. THAT THAT'S
THE THE REASON REALLY THE MAIN
REASON FOR OR BIASING SOME OF
THIS MONEY TOWARD DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS REAL WATER IN THIS
MEASURE ITS OF WATER COMING FROM
WASTE WATER RECYCLING A DE
SALTING. AGRICULTURAL URBAN
WATER CONSERVATION A WIDE
VARIETY OF OTHER PROVEN
PRODUCTION METHOD SO THAT WHAT
MEASURE. THE MEASURE WILL
PRODUCE REAL WATER FOR
CALIFORNIA.
A KEY EL LAW THAT YOU PASSED THE
END OF THE LOT OF CREDIT GOES TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THIS WAS THE
SUSTAINABLE GROW WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT.
WE PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO IT'S
AN ACT THAT'S NOW GOING INTO
EFFECT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THE
WATER DISTRICTS ARE TAKING IT
VERY SERIOUSLY. BUT THAT WE HAVE
NOT FUNDED IN A BIG WAY YET NOW
IS THE TIME TO BEGIN TO FUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT BILL
BECAUSE OUR WATER SUPPLIES ARE
REALLY OUT OF BALANCE DUE TO
GROW WATER OVERDRAFT.
AS WAS MENTIONED WE DO HAVE
WATER FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE I
WANT EMPHASIZE ONE CATEGORY
AND THAT IS THE NEED TO RESTORE
DELTA FISHERIES
ONE OF THE MAIN PROBLEMS WE HAVE
WITH THE STATE AND FEDERAL WATER
PROJECTS AND ALSO LOCAL ONES
LIKE COUNTRY BECAUSE WATER
DISTRICT. IS THE FACT THAT WE
CANNOT EXPORT THE WATER WE NEED
FROM THE DELTA BECAUSE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE TO HAVE OUT
FLOW THROUGH THE DELTA FOR
ENDANGERED FISH SPECIES.
WE HAVE PROVEN METHODS TO BRING
THOSE FISH BACK IT CAN BE DONE
ITS NOT A PIPE DREAM WE'VE SEEN
OUR THE OH BYPASS THAT YOU CAN
RESTORE THE SPECIES. BUT IT'S
QUITE EXPENSIVE SO WE HAVE A
LARGE INVESTMENT THAT YOU MIGHT
SAY IS FISHERIES BUT IN FACT
IT'S ALL ABOUT WATER SUPPLY. AND
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE THAT IS
TO TRY TO RESTORE THOSE SPECIES
AND ALSO TO FIRM UP OUR WATER
SUPPLIES.
WE THINK THE FUNDS IN THE
MEASURE ARE DISTRIBUTED FAIRLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE WE HAVE
A LOT OF DATA ABOUT WHAT EACH
DISTRICT WOULD BENEFIT BY WE
THINK THAT'S BEEN DONE FAIRLY.
AND JUST IN CLOSING WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF THOSE WHO'VE ENDORSED
THIS MEASURE.
OF FIRST OF ALL AGRICULTURE WERE
TREMENDOUSLY IMPRESSED THEY HAVE
THE FARM BUREAU AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL THE.
WESTERN GROWERS AND MANY
COMMODITY GROUPS ENDORSING US
AND HELPING US TO GET MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY SUPPORTIVE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP BIZ FED
BELLY INDUSTRY COVERS
ASSOCIATION BAYER COUNCIL MANY
OTHER BUSINESS GROUPS AND LOCAL
CHAMBERS.
A CITY WILL TALK ABOUT THE WATER
SUPPORT I'M SURE BUT WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE AN UNUSUAL PAIRING. OF
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
SUSPICION IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER COALITION WE
DON'T GET THAT EVERY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA WATER POLITICS.
AND FINALLY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND MANY
OTHER GROUPS WE HAVE MORE THAN
SEVENTY ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS WHO
ENDORSE THIS MEASURE STATE
FEDERAL NATIONAL. I KNOW THIS
YEAR CLUB OPPOSE THE GONNA TALK
TO YOU I'M THE FORMER CHAIR OF
THIS YEAR CLUB WATER COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A DIFFERENCE IN THIS
MEASURE BUT WE ARE VERY HAPPY
WITH THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE A BRIEF PRESENTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR GARCIA AND
MEMBER CINDY TALK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES.
AWKWARD WE REPRESENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON THEY ARE BIG AND
SMALL TOGETHER THEY PROVIDE
ABOUT NINETY PERCENT OF THE
WATER THAT'S DISTRIBUTED IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE PUBLIC FOR
AGRICULTURE IN FOR BUSINESS
NGUYEN TO TOUCH VERY BRIEFLY ON
FIVE TOPICS ONE IS OUR POSITION.
TO SAFE DRINKING WATER THREE
GROUND WATER FOR WATER
CONSERVATION AND ON FIVE JUST
TOUCH ON SALTON SEA.
SO FIRST ON OUR POSITION OR
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MET LAST
NOVEMBER THEY TOOK UP BOTH THIS
BOND AND PROP SIXTY EIGHT REVIEW
THEM TOGETHER. AND DECIDED TO
SUPPORT BOTH BOND SO WE ARE IN
SOURCING BOTH OF THEM.
LAST NOVEMBER AT OUR FALL
CONFERENCE WE HAVE A PANEL
REGARDING THE TO BONDS PROP
SIXTY EIGHT IN THIS BOND WE
INVITED THE PROPONENTS FROM BOTH
MEASURES TO COMES SO THAT OUR
MEMBERS COULD LEARN ABOUT BOTH
OF THEM. AND THE PROPONENTS SAID
AT OUR CONFERENCE THAT THE TWO
MEASURES ARE COMPLEMENTARY AND
WE AGREE WITH THAT I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT ON FACT TO TAKE
HOME FROM THIS THIS HEARING.
WE ALSO THINK THAT THIS BOND
WILL HELP IMPLEMENT FEE BROWN
ADMINISTRATIONS CALIFORNIA WATER
ACTION PLAN THAT PLAN TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO WATER
THE ITEMS THAT I OR I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT ARE. PART OF THAT
PLAN ON BUT THERE ARE OTHER
ELEMENTS WHICH I WON'T GO INTO
ON. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
SO GETTING RIGHT INTO THE ITEMS
SAFE DRINKING WATER MISTER MALE
TOUCHED ON THAT. THIS SPOON
WOULD INCLUDE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER THAT IS
PRIORITIZE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO.
PROP SIX STATE WITH TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION YOU MAY ASK NO
WASN'T THERE SOME MONEY IN PROP
ONE FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAN
THERE WAS THERE WAS THERE WAS
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION. THE
STATE WATER BOARD HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB OF ALLOCATING THAT
MONEY AND THEY TELL US THAT THAT
MONEY IS BASIC EITHER ALLOCATED
OR IN PROCESS.
SO THAT MONEY IS IS REALLY
OBLIGATED.
THAT'S THE REPORT FROM THE STATE
WATER BOARD.
SO WE THINK THIS MONEY IS
GREATLY NEEDED AND WILL HELP
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THEN MOVING ON TO GROUND WATER
THIS BOND.
HAVE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN IT FOR
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT WORK.
IF YOU WERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. THAT WAS THE
YEAR END EXCUSE ME THAT THE BOND
WAS GOING THROUGH THE WATER BOND
WAS GOING THROUGH BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THE WORKMEN SEGMENT
WITH HAPPENING. AND SEGMENT
WASN'T FINISH TILL NEAR THE END
OF SESSION AND I THINK HAD IT
BEEN FINISHED EARLIER.
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN MORE MONEY
IN PROP ONE THAT IT WAS ALMOST
LIKE TO SNEAKING IT IN AT THE
END FOR GROUNDWATER ON THE
SIGNAL MONEY AND. IT INCLUDED A
HUNDRED MILLION THAT IT'S
ALREADY HOME DONE.
AND BY THE WAY HAVE TO
COMPLEMENT THE RESOURCES AGENCY
FOR. BEING VERY TRANSPARENT YOU
CAN GO ON THEIR WEBSITE AND SEE
WHERE EVERY PART OF PROP ONE HAS
GONE IN AND THAT KIND OF THING
IT'S VERY HELPFUL.
THE INSIGNIA IMPLEMENTATION IT
REQUIRED THE CREATION OF SYSTEM
SUSTAINABLE GRAHAM WATER
AGENCIES THE GSA'S. OUR
GRANDMOTHER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES THERE ARE NO TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT OF THOSE
CREATED SO WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT NEW LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT ARE CHARGED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE SLAVIC HAVE TO
DEVELOP PLANS. AND THEN
IMPLEMENT THEM SO THIS MONEY IN
IN IN THIS POND WOULD ALLOW ON
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE PROJECTS TO
GO FORWARD.
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN PROJECTS TO
GO FORWARD THERE'S MONEY YOU CAN
USE FOR SALT WATER INTRUSION
PROJECTS WHICH IS SO SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE ON THE CENTRAL COAST.
AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLANS SO
WE THAT'S ONE OF THE PIECES OF
THE SPAWN THAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE
REALLY FOCUSED ON REALLY
CRITICAL FUNDING.
THEN FOURTH ON CONSERVATION THE
LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED HARD THIS
YEAR THERE'S TWO BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. AND
THAT'S WORKING TO MAKE
CONSERVATION A WAY OF LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS FUND WOULD
INCLUDE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR WATER CONSERVATION AND IT
SPECIFIES THAT THAT MONEY CAN GO
FOR THINGS LIKE TURF REMOVAL
LEAK DETECTION WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
ON TWELVE REPLACEMENT WATER
METERS AND PROJECTS THAT NOT
ONLY CONSERVE WATER BUT SAVE
ENERGY.
SO YOU THINK THAT'S A GREAT
CATEGORY IN THIS BOND.
AND THE LAST WHEN I WAS GING TO
TOUCH ON THE SALTON SEA THE
SPAWNING CLUES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE SALTON SEA. AND
TWENTY MILLION OF THAT AT LEAST
TWENTY MILLION LOGO FOR NEW
RIVER WORK WHICH IS CRITICAL IF
YOU'VE EVER. BEEN DOWN IN TOWARD
THAT AREA I YOU KNOW MONEY IS
NEEDED.
SO THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY
NOT BE GLAD TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
RIGHT. ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
QUESTIONS.
SO.
THERE'S MANY MANY ASPECTS OF
THIS THAT I. Y. CAN THAT
DEFINITELY BENEFIT MY DISTRICT.
.
MY BIGGEST QUESTION AND KIND OF
CONCERN HERE IS.
YOU KNOW DO DOING RECHARGE DOING
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP.
BUT WHAT I'VE SEEN IN THE PAST
IN IN VIETNAM TOURS IN IN.
HE EVEN VISITING COACHELLA
VALLEY AND SEEN SONG SEE.
THAT THE PROBLEM THAT WE KEEP
RUNNING INTO IS WE THROW MONEY
AT IT.
AND WE'LL GET A TREATMENT CENTER
AND OR WHAT WILL GET SOMETHING
FOR TOGETHER FLOYD.
THE FOLKS IN THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES JUST SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO KEEP RUNNING THE
FACILITIES THAT WE BUILT.
AND I'VE SEEN THIS OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
SO MY CONCERN IS THE ONGOING
FUNDS BEYOND THE BALL.
NON.
YOU KNOW ARE WE DOING ANYTHING
WITHIN THIS TO SPEED UP THE AYE
OUR PROCESSES.
OF FOR GROUND WATER RECHARGE.
YOU KNOW HOW WE GONNA GET PASS
THE THE SEQUEL PROCESS ON DOING
THIS.
ON THE THERE SEVERAL ASPECTS
HERE THAT I THINK. THERE WERE
STILL KINDA MISSING. IT I THINK
REALLY HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BLOOD I I'VE GOT A LOT
OF CONCERNS BECAUSE.
I SEE IT ON THE DAY TO DAY BACK
ON MY DISTRICT SPECIALLY CUT
COMING FROM THE CITY OF PORTABLE
WERE WERE WHICH IS DEALT WITH
THE CITY WITHOUT WATER FOR FIVE
YEARS.
THE OTHER EMERGENCY DRINKING
WATER FUND IT IS GREAT BUT IT
RUNS OUT.
AND WITH BONDS THE MONEY IS
GREAT BUT IT RUNS OUT AND.
WHAT ARE WE DOING AS AN ON
GOING?
SUSTAINABILITY.
BECAUSE WHAT WHAT I SEE AS A LOT
OF GREAT THINGS ARE NOT AGREE
PROJECTS THAT THAT HAVE NEEDED
TO HAPPEN YOU KNOW OF A DECADE
AGO.
AND AND NOW WE'RE GIVING THE
MONEY IN THIS BONTA TO PUT
FORWARD TO THE VOTERS.
BOY. A AT THE END OF THE DAY
AFTER THE PROJECTS COMPLETE.
WHAT IS THERE ON THE MAIN SIDE
FOR ONGOING EXPENSE?
HOW ARE WE SPEEDING UP THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE TO GET IT
BUILT?
QUICKER FASTER AND SOONER.
A ONE OF MY BIGGEST CROATIANS I
KEEP BRINGING UP AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL.
AND IN REGARDS THE SIGMA HE'S
THE ONLY WAY TO DO TRUE RECHARGE
EXPRESSLY IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
IF YOU GOT TO GET THROUGH THE
CLAY LAYER WHICH INVOLVES
INJECTION WELLS WHICH ARE
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
THE HOUSE APART A QUESTION YOU
FOLKS IS THE IS THIS GONNA COVER
THE COST OF INJECTION WELLS.
PAIRED WITH.
.
YOU KNOW WETLANDS HABITAT
BECAUSE YOU ONLY SEE DO OUR.
WELL THIS HABITAT FOR WATERFOWL
INDOOR PLUMBING BASE AND IN THE
END SEEK.
GRAVITY INJECTION WELL RIGHT
THE MIDDLE OF IT.
ON I KNOW I'VE HAD TALKS WITH
WATER BOARD MEMBERS ON DOING
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WHY?
YOU NO IT IN THAT I MEAN IT'S
WATER IS STILL HOLISTIC AND IT'S
SUCH A.
SAYING WHERE YOU CAN'T JUST SAY
WE'RE GOING TO DO RECHARGE
BECAUSE RECHARGE GONNA. THE
GROUNDWATER.
AND YOU KNOW THE CONTAMINATION
IN THOSE THINGS FOR CLEANING UP
AS WELL.
ARE.
YOU KNOW SO IT'S.
OBVIOUSLY THIS DOES PROVIDE MORE
WATER.
AND MORE FRESH WATER IN IT FIXES
SOME OF THE CONVEYANCE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE DEALT WITH.
.
BUT IT'S MY IT MY REAL CONCERN
IS WE'RE GOING TO ALL THESE
GREAT THINGS.
IF THE VOTERS PASSED THE BALL I.
WHERE DOES IT LEAVE THE
SUSTAINABILITY SIDE SO IF YOU
CAN MOTHER BUT GREAT DRESS SOME
OF THAT? FAMILIAR CAN TRY TO
TAKE THEM THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M
GONNA GET BACK HOME VERY POINT
WHEN I TALK TO FOLKS BACK HOME
THEY THEY LAY ASSEMBLYMAN. WOLFE
WELL THAT'S GREAT WE'RE GONNA
THROW MORE MONEY AT THE PROBLEM
FULL I.
YOU KNOW HOW WE GONNA DO THIS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AFTER
THIS RESULT SO IF YOU THOSE
ISSUES THEY'RE ALL CRITICAL
ISSUES AND AND AND VERY WELL
THOUGHT OUT. THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE NEW FACILITIES ARE
AFFORDABLE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES REALLY IMPORTANT AND
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
PROBLEMS. PORTERVILLE I THINK
WAS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THE
SOLUTION TO THAT PROBLEM
CONNECTING THOSE.
AREAS THE YEAR OF NO OR POOR
WATER WITH OTHER DISTRICTS WHO
NEAR NEARBY WHO ARE WELL FUNDED.
CAN MANAGE THE SYSTEMS AND NOT
HAVE TO RELY TOTALLY ON THE
PEOPLE WHO WRE JUST BEING
CONNECTED UP AND THERE'S AN
INTERESTING REPORT BY I THINK
WAS PP I SEE.
SHOWING THE NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS FUNDING BUT
WHO ARE REALLY NEARBY LIKE FIVE
HUNDRED FEET FROM A LOCAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT. THAT JUST
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO CONNECT
UP AND I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
WAY TO HANDLE THE PROBLEM THOSE
SMALL REALLY TINY COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE REALLY POOR. THEY DO
HAVE THE PROBLEM OF MAINTENANCE
WE ALLOW THREE YEARS OF
MAINTENANCE MONEY BUT ULTIMATELY
WE HAVE TO SOLVE THAT.
SO. I THINK THE BOARD IS GOING
TO GIVE PREFERENCE WHERE THERE'S
A NEARBY YOUR GOSHEN DISTRICT OR
WATER DISTRICT TO DO
CONNECTIONS.
AND THAT IS PORTABLE THE CLASSIC
EXAMPLE OF HOW YOU CAN SOLVE THE
PROBES A WONDERFUL PICTURE IN
THEIR REPORT OF A COUPLE IN
PORTABLE GETTING THEIR NEW WATER
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN IT. I WAS
THERE YEAH.
SO THAT IS A MODEL WE NEED TO
FOLLOW THEIR OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE JUST TOO FAR. AND THOSE
ARE GONNA HAVE TO FIND DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS AND MAYBE TRY TO
ACCUMULATE THEM AT LEAST INTO
ONE SISTER THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
MY BIGGEST CONSIDER THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE PROBLEM. FIFTH OF
MILES ON THE MIDDLE OF NO WHERE
AND THERE'S A COUPLE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE. AYE AYE
SCENE ARSENIC TREATMENT PLANTS
THAT ARE BRAND NEW THAT THEY
JUST SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD TO RUN
ITS IT IT'S A COMPLETE PROBLEM
AND WE CAN'T HAVE A BOND GOING
PAYING ON THE GOING SUBSIDIES
OBVIOUSLY. SO THE WATER BOARD
ETHNIC A PRETTY HARD LOOK AT IT
AND NOT PUT IN SOMETHING THAT
SIMPLY CAN'T BE OPERATED. BUT I
WILL SAY THIS OF THE NEED
ACCORDING TO THE WATER BOARD IS
IN THE MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TOTALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND WE
DIRECT THEM TO DO PROJECTS THAT
CAN BE FINANCED BY THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND THEY JUST HAVE TO
HAVE A HARD LOOK AND SAY WE.
CAN'T GIVE YOU SOMETHING YOU
CAN'T AFFORD TO MAINTAIN BUT
THERE ARE PLENTY OF OTHER ONES
WHERE THEY CAN OR CONNECT UP.
I DO WANT TO ADDRESS YOU GROW
WATER POINT WHICH IS REALLY
GOOD.
A I DID TO HER FIREBAUGH
RECENTLY AND THEY HAVE A PLACE
WHERE THEY HAD A FORMER ORCHARD
BUT THEY SAID NO WE NEED TO
RECHARGE GROUNDWATER AND
THEY'RE.
FARTHER EAST OF THE CLAY LAYERS
NOT INTERFERING WITH THEM AND IT
IS POSSIBLE TO HELP STABILIZE
GROUNDWATER LEVELS BY PUTTING IN
RECHARGE ESPECIALLY THE FLOOD
WATER WHICH IS THE MOST
AVAILABLE.
TO TRY TO STABILIZE THESE WELL
SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
TAKEN OUT OF PRODUCTION IN THESE
COMMUNITIES CAN CONTINUE TO USE
THEM.
SO SICK MORE I THINK OFFERS US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO STABILIZE
GROW WATER IN PLACES WHERE THEY
ARE RELYING ON SHALLOW WELLS NOW
IF YOU'RE FURTHER ON THE WEST
SIDE YOU HAVE A CLEAR PROBLEM.
INJECTIONS PRAGUE AB THE WAY
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH WITH THE
BOND WORKS IS.
WHATEVER THEY WANT SO THE LOCAL
AGENCY GOES TO THE STATES HAS
HERE'S OUR PLAN HERE'S OUR
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN.
WE THINK WE'LL SHOW THESE
BENEFITS YOU FUNDED NDW ARE OFF
TO MAKE THE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHICH PLANS TO FUND. BUT BOTH
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE BOTH INJECTION
AND GROUND WATER AFTER YOU
THROUGH THE OUR PROCESS THEY DO
OF ALTHOUGH SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE
STATUTORILY EXEMPT LIKE THE
FIREBALL PROJECT BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T AFFECT ANY NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT WAS AN OLD ORCHARD.
AND THEY SIMPLY DUG THE PIT SO
IF THERE ARE WAYS SOMETIMES TO
AVOID THAT AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT THAT THE.
SORRY FOR THE LONG.
NO THANK YOU IT'S IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY FOR PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING PIECES.
I. GUESS I'M STILL LIVING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANKS FOR THE PRESENTATION I
GOT STUCK SOME BASIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT. KIND OF THE THE TIMING OF
THE ISSUANCE OF THE BONDS TO
HAVE THE MONEY THAT YOU WANT TO
DO FOR THE PROJECTS THAT YOU
WANT TO DO. AND
THE FACT THAT THE STATE HAS A
DOLLARS ISSUED ALL BONDS
APPROVED TO BE ISSUED.
SO YOU HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT
IS THAT A PRACTICAL HOW IT
CHALLENGE SO CAN YOU DRESS THAT
AND ALSO. THAT THE SEQUENCING OF
HOW FAST IS THE SPENDING THE
MONEY YES BUT IN FACT IN OUR
MUTUAL DISTRICT OTHERS AND GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THAT THE SMART TREAT.
ADDITION OF THAT MY REFORM
ORGANIZATION DIDN'T NINETEEN
NINETY ALLOCATED MONEY FOR THE
SMART TRAIN. BUT THE LOCAL
COUNTIES WERE NOT ABLE TO
APPROVE AND IMPLEMENT THAT
PROJECT FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
AFTER THAT PASSED.
SO THE BONDS ARE NEVER SOLD THE
STATE INCURRED NO INTEREST AND
THEN FINALLY THE SMART AGENCY
SAID OKAY WERE READY AND THEY
WANT TO THE STATE SAID OKAY NOW
YOU CAN SELL THAT LAST BIT OF
REMAINING BONDS FROM PROP ONE
SIXTEEN. AND SO FORTUNATELY WHEN
A STATE AGENCY IS NOT READY TO
IMPLEMENT A PROJECT THERE'S NO
STATE DEBT INCURRED AND SO WE
CAN WAIT AND AND IT MAY. BE MANY
YEARS SOMETIMES IN THAT CASE IT
WAS.
HOWEVER OF WHEN THE STATE IS
READY THE GO TO THE THE LOCAL
AGENCY WOULD APPLY LET'S SAY A
LOCAL WATER DISTRICT WAS
APPLYING TO. DE OF YOU ARE FOR
GRANT FOR ONE OF THESE PROJECTS.
THEY WOULD SAY OKAY HERE'S A
PROJECT A WE THINK IT'S COULD BE
APPROVED OFTEN THE STATE WILL
SAY YOU MUST PAY FOR THE PROJECT
YOURSELF WILL REIMBURSE YOU
THAT'S THE TYPICAL WAY THE STATE
OPERATES. AND SO FINALLY AFTER
THE PROJECT WAS BUILT IN THE
REIMBURSEMENT WAS REQUESTED THE
STATE WOULD GO TO THE PULLMAN
INVESTMENT ACCOUNT OF THE
TREASURE AND SAY NOW'S THE TIME
SO BONDS ARE NEVER SOLD INTEREST
IS NEVER OCCURRED. OFTEN UNTIL
THE PROJECT IS ACTUALLY
COMPLETED WHICH IS THE MOST
DESIRABLE WAY TO DO IT BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO DEFER THAT DEBT AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE.
BUT THERE IS THE ANALYST DIE HAS
ON THEIR WEBSITE A REALLY GOOD
ANALYSIS OF THE REMAINING FUNDS
IN A LOT OF BONDS.
OF PROP ONE NOW THEY HAVE THE
THE.
LARGE ALLOCATION OF STORAGE WAS
THERE JUST NOW APPROVING
OBVIOUSLY.
AND DOES SO NO STATE BONDS HAVE
BEEN SOLD FOR THAT BUT THEY WILL
BE STARTING NEXT YEAR.
SO TYPICALLY A BOND OF THIS SIZE
IS THE ANALYST SAID WOULD TAKE
TEN YEARS TO COMPLETELY SPEND
DOWN PROBABLY FIVE OR SIX YEARS
TO MOSTLY SPENT DOWN THERE WOULD
BE THE NORMAL TIMELINE FOR
THESE.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION.
PLATE IF IT DOES BUT I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT THE OTHER. CONCERN I
HAVE MISTER MERRILL IS THAT THIS
IS A.
AN INITIATIVE THAT THAT
ESSENTIALLY WAS BROUGHT DIRECTLY
TO VOTERS RATHER THAN HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE. OR THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ADMINISTRATION ESSENTIALLY
WEIGH IN ON THAT.
AND.
I WHETHER THERE WOULD BE
RETICENCE IN.
THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE FUTURE
TO GO AHEAD AND ISSUE THOSE
BONDS IN AND IN FACT.
RECOMMEND FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
GO AHEAD AND DO PRIOR SPENDING
TO THE ISSUANCE OF THOSE BONDS
WITH IF THERE'S ANY UNCERTAINTY
BECAUSE OF THAT.
I WANTED THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
UNDERSTAND. SO I AM AWARE OF AT
LEAST THREE BONDS OF FOUR FIVE
BONDS IT DIDN'T USE ISSUE
PROCESS.
A PARK BOND REAL BOND
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL INTO WATER
BONDS OF AND MAY BE FORGETTING
SOMETHING.
BUT IN ALL THOSE CASES UNDER
BOTH REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONS THEY TREAT THEM
JUST LIKE REGULAR BONDS THERE'S
NEVER BEEN ANY HESITANCE TO
PROVE OF THE ISSUANCE OF BONDS
DONE TO THE INITIAL PROCESS
COMPARED TO THE OTHER. AND IN
FACT IN MY OWN OBSERVATION OF
THE ACTIONS OF FINANCING OF THE
DEPARTMENTS.
THEY TAKE THEM PRETTY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE AFTER ALL THE VOTERS DID
APPROVE THE.
SO SO FAR HAS BEEN A PROBABLY
CAN'T SPEAK OF THE FUTURE BUT
HISTORICALLY IT HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM.
I'M I'M GONNA PAKSHA TO LEAVE
HERE IN A LITTLE BIT BUT I
WANTED TAKEN UP TO YOU TO.
ADDRESS SOME OF THEM WILL GO TO
MISTER WOOD.
IF MISTER LEVINE MAYBE COULD
TAKE OVER CHAIRMANSHIP THAT
AFTER THIS.
AT WORK OR MISTER.
.
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S A LOT
TO LIKE.
IN THIS BOND THAT MISTER MARROW.
BY SUPPOSE THAT'S ALSO THE
GREATEST.
PROBLEM.
WITH IT WITH YOUR BOND AS WELL
RIGHT IS YOU KNOW SOME OF SOME
OF DESCRIBED IT AS A CHRISTMAS
TREE RIGHT THAT THERE'S.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS FOR ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE. AND SO PEOPLE CAN SAY
WELL HEY THAT'S GREAT IT'S
ADDRESSING ALL THE DIFFERENT.
NEEDS THEY'RE OUT THERE BUT IN
DOING SO WE HAVE A PRETTY BIG
BOND HERE WE HAVE. YAMAHA NINE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND.
AFTER WE'VE JUST APPROVED A
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BOND ON THE
BALLOT. AND YOU KNOW HERE JUST
RECENTLY. AT THE LA OUR REPORT.
VERY CLEARLY LAYS OUT THE MORE
PAIN ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEBT SERVICE JUST ON OUR AND
NATURAL RESOURCES BONDS.
THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
.
AND I GUESS.
THE THING THAT I THINK ABOUT
WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TO A BONDS
IS. REALLY WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
ABOUT IS HELPING LOCALS.
YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE LOCALS CAN.
TOLLEY COME UP WITH THE MONEY TO
DO VITAL PROJECTS THE BONDS HELP
THEM DO THAT RIGHT.
.
AND PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT WAYS WE'VE DONE THAT
IS THROUGH PROPOSITION ONE KNEE
AND LET LEVY BONDS.
WHERE WE'VE?
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE A.
STRENGTHENED IN CERTAIN PLACES
ARE ARE LEVEES LOCALS PROBABLY
COULD COME UP THAT ALL THEY HAVE
TAX THEMSELVES.
AND.
BUT IN ADDITION TO HAVING THE
BOND SUPPORT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
TO IMPROVE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
OVERALL.
.
AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK.
PERHAPS IT THIS WAS A LITTLE BIT
MORE FOCUSED IN ON ON JUST THAT.
AND.
THIS BAR MAYBE WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN AS.
AS LARGE IT IS AS IT HAS
PROPOSED RIGHT NOW.
AND I GUESS THE OTHER CONCERN.
THAT WOULD LAY OUT IS.
AND MAYBE ONE OF THE THINGS.
TO THINK ABOUT ISN'T THERE ARE
PLACES IN THIS BOMB WHERE. I
WILL COME
SORT OF BAILOUTS AND.
FOR STATE AGENCIES A.
AND AND FOR TAKING CARE OF WHAT
I REALLY STATE AGENCIES
RESPONSIBILITIES.
.
AND YOU KNOW THAT SEEMS TO BE
KIND OF THE OPPOSITE OF HELPING.
LOCALS MEET YOU KNOW SOME OF
THEIR. NEEDS AND OBLIGATIONS
RIGHT SO FOR INSTANCE
YOU KNOW WHERE'S TWO HUNDRED
MILLION AND THEREFORE THE
OROVILLE DAM REPAIRS.
THAT'S A RESPONSIBILITY OF
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES IN
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS.
IS NOT THE RESPONSIBILITY OF.
YOU KNOW MY KIDS MY GRAND
CHILDREN.
YEAR TO PAY OFF BY MONEY TO
TAKE CARE THAT.
ANOTHER ONE I WOULD HIGHLIGHT
IS PAIN.
VW OURS AND THREE OTHER.
AGENCIES.
A CAP AND TRADE.
A.
ENERGY COSTS RIGHT THERE WERE
ESSENTIALLY GONNA SUBSIDIZE WHAT
THEIR PAIN.
AND WHAT THE INCREASING COSTS OF
THEIR PAIN BECAUSE A CAP AND
TRADE FOR THREE.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WE DON'T DO
THAT FOR.
FRANCE'S A CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER
WHO'S PICKING UP THAT IN THEIR
ENERGY COSTS. AND AND SO MANY
OTHER AREAS BUT WE'RE GONNA DO
IT.
FIRST SIMPSON BIG GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
.
YOU KNOW.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
IT'S REALLY PROBLEMATIC.
ABOUT THIS BOND NOW IT'S YOU
KNOW MAYBE ASK YOU TO JUST
ADDRESS.
THOSE TWO AREAS OKAY WELL YOU
KNOW IN IN THE IN THE CASE OF
THE STATE WATER PROJECT.
PARA COULD QUOTE POGO AND SAY
WE HAVE MET THE ENEMY AND HE IS
US BECAUSE.
MORE THAN SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE ACTUALLY GET
WATER FROM THE STATE WATER
PROJECT OR YOUR GATE THEIR
FIELDS OR THINGS LIKE THAT AND
SO. A. IN THE CASE OF ORVILLE OF
THE CORPS OF ENGINEERS PAID FOR
THE FLOOD CONTROL ELEMENTS OF
ORVILLE ORIGINALLY THAT NOT THE
WATER CONTRACTORS AND THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE FLOOD
CONTROL IS ALWAYS BEEN
CONSIDERED GENERAL FUND.
OBLIGATION AND AS I THE PAPER
FIVEPERCENT READ OF THE TO A
LESS THAN FIVE PERCENT WAS A LOT
MORE THAN THAT BUT. WELL THEN IT
WHATEVER IT WAS IT WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT TODAY WOULD
BE HUNT MANY HUNDREDS MISS NINE
AT THAT TABLE WAS A NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT WATER SUPPLY PROJECT. IN
TERMS OF BENEFITS BUT I BELIEVE
THE COR PAID MORE F THAT IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE IS A
FRACTION OF THE COST I COULD I
COULD GO BACK AND SEE WHAT I
THINK IT WAS MORE THAN.
BUT BUT IN THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS INEVITABLY ARE GOING
TO PICK UP A LOT OF THE COST OF
REPAIRING ORVILLE BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THEME IS GOING TO
PAY AS MUCH AS THE STATE IS
ASKED US TO PAY ASK THEM TO PAY.
BUT THE FLOOD CONTROL BENEFITS
ORVILLE ARE.
I DON'T TO SAY HARMFUL BUT LET'S
SAY NOT COMPATIBLE WITH THE
WATER SUPPLY AILMENTS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOWERING THE
RESERVE WHERE FOR FLOOD CONTROL
YOU REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
STORAGE YOU CAN USE LATER ON.
AND IF IT DOESN'T RAIN YOU
PROBABLY CAN'T REFILL IT STIRRED
SO YOU SACRIFICED WATER POWER
BENEFITS REPORT CONTROL THAT'S A
GOOD TRADE OFF THAT'S PUBLIC
POLICY IT'S A GOOD THING. BUT
IT'S DETRIMENTAL TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE RECEIVING WATER POWER
FROM THE PROJECT.
AND SO.
BUT THE IDEA OF THE STATE PAYING
SOME PROBABLY ONLY GET IN THE
END TWENTY PERCENT OR LESS OF
THE COST OF FIXING ORVILLE. BUT
NOT ONLY OR.
I THINK IT'S FAIR IN TERMS OF
ITS GENERAL FUND BENEFITS THE
FLOOD CONTROL BENEFITS.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE AFTER ALL IN
THE END MOST OF THE PEOPLE THE
STATE ARE BENEFICIARIES OF STATE
WATER PROJECT EVERYONE SOUTH THE
TEHACHAPI IS IN MOST OF THE BAY
AREA AND MOST OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY A LOT OF IT. SOUTHERN END
OF IS A BENEFICIARY.
AND I UNDERSTAND YOU GO EITHER
WAY AND THAT AND I RESPECT THE
IDEA THAT MAYBE THE CONTRACT YOU
SHOULD PAY FOR ALL OF IT. BUT
STILL A IT'S A PRETTY SMALL
FRACTION AND PROBABLY NOT
RADICALLY DIFFERENT FROM THE WAY
FLOOD CONTROL WAS FUNDED
ORIGINALLY I KNOW THAT ISN'T
ANSWERED SATISFIES EVERYBODY BUT
IT'S OUR RATIONALE FOR MATT WELL
OF COURSE AND I THINK YOU KIND
OF ALLUDED TO IT BUT. I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE DRIVEN HOME. THE THE
THE COST OF HAVING A WATER
SUPPLY PROJECT.
YOU KNOW FOR THE STATE ALSO
MEANS DOING WHAT IT TAKES TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE THAT.
RIGHT LIVE DOWNSTREAM OF IT.
NEW AND WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE PEOPLE ARE
SAFE SHOULD BE DONE WELL PAT
BROWN YOU KNOW I SIT AND THAT OR
WILL BE BUILT BEFORE THE STATE
WATER PROJECT PEOPLE SAID IT WAS
NEEDED. IN FACT THEY WERE RIGHT
THEY DIDN'T NEED OR BILL BUT HE
FLEW OVER MARYSVILLE YUBA CITY
AND FIVE AND SAID WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THIS HAPPEN AGAIN
AND OF COURSE THAT WAS WONDERFUL
AND THEN ORVILLE SERVE THAT
FUNCTION SO. RATES A MONTH
ACOSTA THAT SHOULD BE BORNE BY
THE BENEFICIARIES RIGHT AND SORT
OF THROW PARTIES AND THE
BENEFICIARIES OF THE WATER
SUPPLY PROJECT LOCAL THAT'S
WHERE IT IS.
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR ARE GONNA
PAY FOR THAT AND AND BON PAIRS.
YOU KNOW THE GENERAL TAXPAYER
SHOULD BE THE ONE THAT'S ON THE
HOOK FOR THAT IT SHOULD BE THOSE
WHO ARE THE BENEFICIARIES OF
THAT. WELL THAT'S IN A NO IF HE
COULD AS THE CAP AND YOU KNOW
WHY ARE WE SUBSIDIZING THE
STATE'S CAP AND TRADE COSTS WERE
NOT SUBSIDIZING.
THE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS I
ACTUALLY THERE IS NO SUBSIDY IN
THAT.
SECTION OF THE BOND
THE MONEY THAT IS PAID.
IN ALLOWANCES BY THOSE AGENCIES
THE STATE WATER PROJECT CONTRA
COSTA ARTIST AND SO ON. BUT WILL
STILL BE PAID THEY STILL HAVE TO
PAY IT NOW INSTEAD OF IT GOING
TO SORT OF A GENERAL CATIA THOSE
FUNDS THEY HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW IF IMPLY THE B. THIRTY
TWO. AND THEY HAVE TO SPEND IT
ON PROJECTS THAT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS TO THE
SAME EXTENT AS IF THE MONEY WAS
SPENT OR ANY OTHER PROJECT. SO
THEY'RE NOT JUST GETTING THE
MONEY BACK THEY HAVE TO SPEND IT
ON ENERGY WATER CONSERVATION TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND THAT HAS TO
BE REVIEWED THAT WILL BE
REVIEWED BY THE AIRPORT SO IT'S
REALLY NOT. ANY KIND OF SUBSIDY
AND THE MONEY WILL STILL BE
SPENT FOR THE SAME ORIGINAL
PURPOSES.
TURN OF MISTER BLOOM AND THEN.
CATHOLIC CONCRETE WITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND TO SEQUESTER FOR
YOU I'VE GOT IT I GOT A LIST
HERE OF DONORS TO THIS
INITIATIVE AND. AND.
BOUT OF MILLION DOLLARS SO FAR
MILLION TO MORE THAN FOUR ONE
POINT TWO THIS IS I'M NOT SURE
WHAT THE DATE ON THIS IS BUT. SO
I'M ALSO NOTICING THAT A LOT OF
THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT.
.
PRIVATE ENTITIES OUT THERE WHERE
THEY WHERE THEY HOPE TO GAIN BY
THE SEAS ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS RIGHT WE'VE
ACTUALLY RAISE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION SO FAR TYPE AND ONE
THIRD OF THAT HAS COME FROM
AGRICULTURE. ONE THIRD FROM
PEOPLE I'D SAY ARE ALIGNED WITH
WATER AGENCIES AND ONE THIRD
FROM CONSERVATION GROUPS AND
WE'RE HAPPY WITH THAT ACTUALLY I
HOPE WE MAINTAIN THAT BALANCE.
ARE SO IN THE CASE OF ALL I I
DON'T WANT TO ALWAYS ATTRIBUTE.
WHY PEOPLE GIVE BUT I'LL GIVE
YOU MY BEST GUESS?
THE CONSERVATION GROUPS SEE THE
BENEFIT OF WATER SUPPLY FOR
WATERFALL OF WATER FOR OTHER
KINDS OF HABITAT OF HABITAT
CONSERVATION WATERSHED
RESTORATION.
BY I WOULD SAY.
THEY'RE DISPASSIONATE IN THE
SENSE THAT ARE GOING TO GET
MONEY OUT OF IT THEMSELVES BUT
THEY JUST HAVE THAT AS A AS AN
OVERALL GOAL.
THE AGRICULTURAL PEOPLE I THINK
RIGHTLY SEE THE THREAT TO
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE FROM. ARE
DIMINISHING WATER SUPPLY IF YOU
LOOK AT HOW MUCH WATER WE'VE
EXPORTED TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE OVER THE
YEARS IT'S GONE DOWN A LOT FOR A
LOT OF REASONS YOU COULD LIST A
WHOLE DIFFERENT SET OF REASONS
AND AND.
.
MANY DIVERSE REASONS BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS ESPECIALLY WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA.
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING TO HELP
AGRICULTURE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
SERIOUS DECLINE IN THEIR
CULTURAL PRODUCTIVITY AND
SILICON VALLEY.
THEN THIS FIXING OF THE FRANKLIN
CANALS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT. A
DOES HAVE TO BE FIXED A LOT OF
THE DONORS FROM THAT AREA NOT
ALL. IN SO I THINK THEY'RE JUST
FEELING THE THREAT OF THEIR
WATER SUPPLY TO.
THEIR FUTURE THEIR WHOLE FUTURE
IN THE STATE THAT'S MY GUESS.
THE WATER PEOPLE ARE REALLY
DIVERSE OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY A CONSTANTLY
REMIND ME IN THEIR BIG DONORS TO
THIS EVER CULTURAL GROUPS IN
SEPARATE AVAIL. CONSTANTLY
REMIND ME THAT. BY REPAIRING
FISHERIES THEIR PRODUCTIVITY CAN
BE SUSTAINED AND SO THEY DIDN'T
ASK FOR NEW WATER FACILITIES OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT NO STORAGE
THEY SAID FIX THE FISH FIX THE
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER IN OUR
REGION. IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY I THINK IS MORE EFFORT TO
FIX THE FRANK KERN CANAL SOME OF
THE OTHER FACILITIES DOWN THERE
SO IT'S PRETTY DIVERSE AND
THAT'S PUBLIC GOOD THING.
AS GLORIA.
THANK YOU SHARON THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION AND IN A VERY.
.
LUCID ANSWER STOOD TO THE
QUESTIONS WE DON'T ALWAYS GET
BETTER OUT OF SIGHT AYE HE SAID.
.
OUT OF MY COLLEAGUES DON'T
THAT'S EXCEPTIONAL JOB OF A
GETTING TO.
SOME OF THINGS I WAS DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHO.
GIVEN THAT YOU HAVE TWO MILLION
BUCKS HAD IMAGINE THERE'S SOME
INDICATION OF THE VOTERS.
WILLINGNESS TO TO DO THIS I'M
MIGHT.
GENERAL TUITION I'M NEW IN THE
LEGISLATURE SO I COULD BE WRONG.
IS THAT THERE MAY BE SOME.
FATIGUE WITH THIS AND THEY JUST
APPROVED A VERY LARGE BOND IN
THE ON YOU KNOW LAST WEEK I'M
HERE. ANOTHER GROUP COMING TO
THE TABLE ASKING AGAIN WHAT'S
THE PUBLIC'S APPETITE FOR DOING
THIS IT MAY BE IN NEED OF IT
THERE'S ALWAYS A NEED THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH RESOURCES IN THIS
IS WATER SO YOU KNOW. IN
CALIFORNIA BUT BUT WHAT IT WHAT
HAVE YOU DISCOVERED IN TERMS
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO DO THIS
AGAIN SO SOON WE'VE HAD A TWENTY
FOUR WATER BONDS ON THE
CALIFORNIA BALLOT SINCE NINETEEN
SIX.
TWENTY THREE OF PASSED.
AND HISTORICALLY.
THEY OF THAT I GOT AN OFFER
THAT BE HAPPY TO SEND YOU BY THE
WAY. WE HISTORICALLY THERE BEEN
CASES WHERE THERE WERE VERY FEW
BANDS ON THE BALLOT OR VERY MANY
BANDS ON THE BALLOT.
NINE TIMES THERE BEEN MORE THAN
ONE WATER BOND ON THE SAME
BALLOT NOT JUST THE SAME YEAR
BUT THE SAME BALLOT. ALL NINE OF
THEM PASSED.
I THINK THE EXPLANATION FOR THAT
AND ALSO BY THE WAY THE MARGINS
DURING DOG RECESSIONS VERSUS
GOOD ECONOMIC TIMES DON'T CHANGE
THAT MUCH IT'S AMAZING.
I THINK PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
GENERALLY DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
WATER COMES FROM IF YOU GET IN
UBER AND LEN ASK THEM THOSE SAY
DWP YOU KNOW THAT'S ABOUT AS
MUCH AS THOUGH NO. BUT THEY KNOW
THEY LIVE IN A DRY PLACE IT
DOESN'T RAIN MUCH.
AND THEY'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT WATER AND SO OUR POLLING
SHOWS THAT WE'RE OVER SIXTY
PERCENT NOW WITHOUT ANY
CAMPAIGN.
IN PROP YOU KNOW SIXTY EIGHT DID
VERY WELL THAT FIFTY SIX
PERCENT.
SO WE'RE NOT TOO WORRIED
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE HISTORY OF
NINE TIMES YOU'VE HAD MORE THAN
ONE IN THE SAME BELT ONCE WE
HAVE THREE WATER BOND ON THE
SAME DAY OUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT
THOSE ARE ALL LEGISLATIVE.
THEY'LL PASSED.
THAT'S THAT'S HELPFUL HAS
REMAINED ABSENCE OF THE SUCCESS
IT'S JUST THE RAPT EXPRESSION
WITHIN JUST A FEW MONTHS OTHER
YOU EDUCATE ME IF THERE WAS.
MULTIPLE ON SENATE STREET.
THAT'S IN THE CONTEXT OF IT HE
WAS GONNA BE A LINK THE GENERAL
ELECTION BALLOT IN NEW WITHIN MY
OWN COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION.
THERE'S A RUN ON THE BANK IF
YOU WILL.
THAT'S HAPPENING SO IT'S PART
OF WHY I ASKED THE QUESTION THAT
YOU CAN YOU HAVE CRIED DATA THAT
SUGGESTS THAT THIS IS OVER THE
ENDEAVOR HOPE. THAT SUCH A CRIME
THE CLINTON SIGNATURES THAT'S
WHY YOU'RE HERE WELL WE'RE
FINISHED WE DEFENSE OCCURS OF
OUR.
.
SO THERE'S NO POTENTIAL FOR
AMENDING THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL THERE IS A LAW THAT
MISTER STEINBERG DID WHEN HE WAS
HERE THAT SAID THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD OFFER.
ALTERNATIVES TO PROPONENTS OF
INITIATIVES AND THAT THE
PROPONENTS UP UNTIL JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTH CAN WITHDRAW THEIR
INITIATIVE AND DOES HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE LEGISLATIVE MEASURE
THAT HAS HAPPENED ONCE ACTUALLY
BUT THERE'S NO DISCUSSIONS LIKE
THAT VOTE TO NOT RIGHT NOW NO.
AND I I GUESS PART OF WHY I ASK
IS THAT SIR INFANTRY
SUBCOMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
THERE'S A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
THAT THEY REYES I THINK ONE THAT
CAUGHT MY EYE. IS.
THE ABILITY TO ALLOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO COMPETE
FOR SOME OF THESE FUNDS CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE WISDOM BEHIND THAT
PROVISIONS. THAT APPLY
SPECIFICALLY TO THE SIERRA
NEVADA CARBS ARE WATERSHED
LITERALLY THE STATE'S WATERSHED
IS THE SOONER THAT WE GET ALL OF
OUR WATER FROM IT FOR WELL ALL
BUT A VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
WATER.
AND MOST OF ITS OWN BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY HAVE
NEVER ALLOCATED THE FUNDS WE
NEED TO RESTORE THOSE WATERSHEDS
AND THIS YEAR NEVADA CONSERVANCY
STRONGLY TOLD US THAT IF WE WANT
TO. RESTORE THOSE FORESTS AND
GET THE WATER QUALITY AND
QUANTITY WE NEED OF THOSE
FORESTS.
THE STATE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
INVEST WE DON'T HAVE TO INVEST
NECESSARILY IN SIERRA PACIFIC
INDUSTRIES LAND THEY DO A GOOD
JOB OF MANAGING A. BUT THESE
FEDERAL LANDS ARE ORPHANS TO
SOME EXTENT IN YOUR IT'S OUR
WATER SUPPLY SO WE LISTEN TO
THIS YEAR OF A CONSERVANCY IN
THAT ISSUED ME THE.
FOR THAT PROVISIONAL IMPLIES THE
SIERRA NEVADA THAT'S THE ONLY
WHEN WE COME.
YES I SAID AT THE OWN WITH NO WE
ALSO INCLUDE FUNDS FOR THE
FRANKLIN CANNELLA REPAIR WHICH
IS TECHNICALLY OWNED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MANAGED BY
THE LOCAL AGENCY. AND SO THAT
WOULD APPLY THERE AS WELL.
SO FORGIVE ME SO THERE'S TWO
PLACES IN WHICH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT APPLY FOR THESE FUNDS
NOTE WELL IN THAT CASE THE FOR
THE LOCAL STATE AGENCY THE FRYER
WATER AGENCY WOULD APPLY NOT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN FACT EVEN
IN THE SIERRA NEVADA I'M SURE
ALL THE FUNDS WOULD GO THROUGH
STATE AGENCIES NOT THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT IT COULD
BE SPENT ON FEDERAL LANDS THAT'S
THE MAIN DIFFERENCE.
AND IN THOSE THAT SECOND FINAL
QUESTION MR OF.
IS THE CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS
PROVISION THAT SO ELIMINATED BY
STAFF CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHY THIS
FROM THE STRUCTURED DIFFERENTLY
THAN OTHER BONDS ACTUALLY THE
ANALYST HAD A.
STILL HERE BUT IN FACT THERE WAS
ONE OTHER ONE A PROPOSITION TWO
OH FOR BY SOMEONE CASA WHICH IS
WATER BOND IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DID APPROVE
WITH CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
I IN ADDITION TO THE ONE THAT
THAT THE ENLISTED MENTION OF
PROPOSITION ONE A LARGE SHARE OF
THAT. AND THEIR THE ANSWER
REALLY WAS OF CONCERN WOULD BE
PERFECTLY HONEST CONCERN BY
PROPONENTS OF CHANGES IN THE
ALLOCATIONS
WHEN PEOPLE SUPPORT THESE BONDS
THROUGH.
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY MADE THEY
WANT TO HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
CERTAINTY THAT THEY'LL ACTUALLY
GET WHAT THEY'RE OF INVESTING IN
IN THE SENSE.
AND SO THAT WAS THE REASON PLUS
PREP TO FORGET A HUGE YES VOTE
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND BY THE
PUBLIC AND SO APPARENTLY THE
PUBLIC WAS PRETTY COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT. THAT PRECEDENT.
YOU'RE SO IT LEGISLATURE MAY NOT
BE A YES I DO.
THEY CAN IS FROM MISTAKES IF
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND FOR AND
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
MARK ME MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
ALASKA.
THE.
REPRESENTED FROM THE SIERRA
CLUB.
TO COME FORWARD.
AND DATA DAVID WOLF.
WHO?
REPRESENTS THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AS WELL.
I THINK YOU GOOD MORNING KYLE
JONES THE SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
AND NOW WE DID TAKE IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS BONDS.
.
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS WHICH
ALL OF TRY TO HURRY IN GETTING
THROUGH.
ONE OF OUR CONCERNS IS IS THE
SIZE OF OF THE BOND ITSELF.
.
YEAH AS WAS ALLUDED TO THE TOTAL
DEBT SERVICING WOULD BE
SOMEWHERE AROUND OVER SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. OP REPRESENTING
A GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
AT AND I BELIEVE THIS PUTS DE
RESOURCES AGENCIES BUDGET OF
OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF IT WILL BE
QUARTET SERVICES.
.
AND THAT'S A HUGE HIT AND AND
AND YOU KNOW AS THE GOVERNOR
LIKES AWARENESS EVERY MAY.
THAT YOU KNOW. BAD TIMES CAN
COME AND THE GENERAL FUND IS
WHAT TAKES THE HARDEST HIT
DURING THOSE TIMES OUT WITH PROP
NINETY EIGHT PROTECTING FUNDS
FOR K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW A FUTURE LEGISLATURE
OR THIS ONE COULD BE FACED WITH
HARD CHOICES ABOUT WHERE TO CUT
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN THIS OUT FROM THE
RESOURCES BUDGET FOR OTHER NEEDY
PROGRAMS. OR IS THAT FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS.
THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE RECENTLY
WORKED HARD TO TO GET PAST
I IT IT AND SO.
THIS SIZE THE BOND I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW RAISE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ARM.
AND WE THINK THAT'S A PART OF
THE REASON THE SIZES SO BIG IS
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF GOING
BONTA THROUGH THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS RATHER THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
I'M.
MISTER GALLAGHER SAID THAT IF
THE BONDS BEEN DESCRIBED AS THE
CHRISTMAS TREE. UP AND WE CAN
AGREE I THINK THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
HERE IS PROBLEMATIC FOR US.
.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
YOU HAVE AN APPROACH WHERE THOSE
WHO CAN WHO WILL SEEK TO BENEFIT
FROM THE BOND OF THOSE WHO ARE
CONTRIBUTING THE BOND TOO AND
THOSE WERE ASKING FOR MORE ITEMS
FOR THE BOND.
IT'S NOT AN OPEN PROCESS FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE A LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS PROBLEM.
I'M SURE CHAIR GARCIA YOU STILL
HAVE SCARS FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT
AND AND AND ALL THE NEGOTIATIONS
I HAD TO GO THROUGH FOR THAT
BUT.
ULTIMATELY GOING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS IS BETTER FOR THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC IS HAS A A
BETTER SEAT AT THE TABLE.
BOB AND AND ALSO BECAUSE OF THIS
PROCESS WE SEE THAT FUND THAT
THAT ITEMS ARE GETTING FUNDED IN
THIS BOND. THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY APPROPRIATE FOR BOND
FUNDING IN OUR VIEW AYE. BONDS
ARE GREAT FOR AS MENTIONED OUT
WHERE LOCALS CAN'T OR MAYBE
WON'T BE AS WILLING TO PAY OR
WHERE WE'RE PUSHING.
AS PUBLIC POLICY.
YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE WATER
RECYCLING WHERE IT'S MAYBE NOT
AS EASY TO GET PEOPLE ON BOARD
FOR A RATE INCREASE FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT THERE'S
THINGS LIKE KLAMATH RIVER. US
DON'T SEE RESTORATION WHERE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE ALREADY IN HOCK.
INSTEAD WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
AS HINK
HERE.
THINGS LIKE ORVILLE WHERE THERE
ARE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES WHO ARE
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO PAY FOR THAT
FUNDING OR THE FRANK CURRENT CAN
NOW WHERE THERE ARE. EITHER
BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE THOSE
RECEIVE THE PROJECTS
OR THEORETICALLY YOU COULD HOLDS
OUT THOSE WHO DAMAGE THE CAN
DOWN THE FIRST PLACE THROUGH
OVER PUMPING OF GROUNDWATER. AT
FAULT
I'M INSTEAD THAT'S THAT'S
GETTING PUSHED ON THE TAXPAYER
AND AND TO THE EXTENT THAT MAYBE
WE SHOULD CONSIDER THINGS ABOUT.
STOP.
WHERE WHERE WE SHIFT THE POLICY
ON THOSE AND WHERE?
WE THINK ABOUT OR BILL AND AND
WHAT ROLE THE FLOOD CONTROL
ABOUT FLOOD CONTROL BENEFIT IT
PROVIDES A THAT IS BEST DONE I
THINK THROUGH DELIBERATE OF
PUBLIC POLICY PROCESS RATHER
THAN A INITIATIVE PROCESS FOR
AVANT.
.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT ALL
OF THESE ITEMS ARE ALL
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED AND
THERE'S NO FUTURE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
AT THIS IS ESSENTIALLY GIVING
AWAY LARGE AMOUNT OF TAXPAYER
MONEY AND AND WE AYE I DON'T
KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT WILL BE ABLE
TO COME BACK AND SEE IT AGAIN.
S. AND IT WITHOUT.
.
BUT THEN I JUST KINDOF WANTED
TO ENDS WITH A DISCUSSION AROUND
THE TEACHER A FUNDING AT THE
MOMENT.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY AGENCIES
WHO PAY INTO THE G. GIRAFFE WILL
GET THAT MONEY BACK.
FORWATER CONSERVATION PROJECTS
AND
OF.
I GUESS ONE THING IT'S NOT CLEAR
TO ME ON THAT IS IS HOW DOES
THAT AFFECT THE OTHER SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE GDR UP THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED SUCH AS HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
ARE ARE THEY STILL PAYING INTO
THAT PORTION OR DOES THAT MEAN
EVERY OTHER INDUSTRY IS NOW.
INCREASING THEIR SHARE OF COSTS
INTO THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND SECONDLY.
THE G. GIRAFFE NEEDS TO FOCUS ON
EFFICIENT CLIMATE REDUCTIONS
WATER CONSERVATION CAN SAVE
ENERGY AND CAN REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
BUT IT MIGHT NOT BE THE MOST
EFFICIENT QUICKEST WAY TO GET
THAT DONE. OUT WE ARE FACING AN
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS OF OUR TIME
AND WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE SPENT.
IN THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY
POSSIBLE.
AND ENDS YOU KNOW TURF
REPLACEMENT
CAN.
YOU KNOW SOUTH ATTACHED PIECE
CAN SAVE SOME ENERGY BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT PUMPING THAT MUCH
WATER OVER THERE BUT.
THAT SHOULDN'T COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF ELECTRIFYING FREIGHT
FLEETS
IN THE SOUTH COAST THAT IS YOU
KNOW PRODUCING A LARGE AMOUNT OF
EMISSIONS AND ALSO IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY AND SAVING LIVES.
SO LOCKING THAT FUNDING AWAY.
FROM ANY CONTROL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IT IS PROBLEMATIC
AND UP FOR THOSE REASONS AND
THERE'S MORE BUT MORE DOWN IN
THE WEEDS I DON'T WANNA PARTY
WHICH DAY.
WE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COME
MORNING DAVID WILL FILE WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION MEDIA APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION FROM THE COMMITTEE
THIS MORNING.
TO SPEAK ON THIS BOND ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT I DO WANT TO
STRESS FROM THE OUTSET THAT THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION HAS NO OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS BOND AT THIS
TIME. ITEM AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
MERELY BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE
SORT OF.
.
OUR THOUGHTS ON HOW WE VIEW ON
TERM DEBT AND DECISIONS ON THIS
BOND SAID THAT BASICALLY MEANS I
GET TO NERD OUT ON FISCAL STUFF
FOR A FEW MINUTES AND.
HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS MORNING
TO DO THAT I WANT TO KNOW FROM
THE OUTSET MISTER CHAIRMAN PITT
HHA IS NOT AUTOMATICALLY OPPOSED
TO ALL STATE GEO BONDS. WE DID
TAKE A NEUTRAL POSITION ON PROP
ONE A SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR BOND
FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN IN WHICH
SHALL ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THAT
MONEY DID GO. TO.
INCREASED WATER STORAGE WATER
CAPACITY PROJECTS LIKE SITES AND
TEMPERANCE FLATS.
THE CONCERNS AND I WOULD STRESS
THEY ARE JUST CONCERNS AT THIS
POINT THAT WE HAVE ABOUT THIS
BOND IS THAT IT'S BIGGER THAN
PROP ONE WITH LESS OF PERCENTAGE
OF THOSE FUNDS. GOING TO VARIOUS
WATER STORAGE PROJECTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND OBVIOUSLY.
WASTE WATER RECYCLING DE SALLE
PROJECTS DO YOU ADD ROLE WATER
AND WE DO THINK THERE'S VALUE TO
THOSE PROJECTS BUT I THINK WE DO
NEED TO ASK BED.
IF IT'S IMPORTANT FOR.
.
THE PROJECTS TO LIE STILL AND
FOR THE BOND WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
A CRIER YOU KNOW IS A PRIORITY.
FOR BOND PROJECTS.
DO YOU DESALINATED STORAGE
PROJECTS DO THEY LOST UNDER THE
BOND PERHAPS BUT ARE THEY THE
BEST USE OF THOSE BOND DOLLARS.
AND COULD EXPANDING RESERVOIRS
AND BUILDING DAMS AND EVEN
ADDING UNDERGROUND STORAGE
AQUIFER RECHARGE TYPE PROJECTS
OF THAT BE A BETTER USE OF BOND
DOLLARS. FOR THE BUCK AND I
THINK.
YOU KNOW DOES NEED TO BE LOOKED
INTO AND YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY
I THINK AS WAS MENTIONED WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE A BOND. THAT GOES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE YOU
POTENTIALLY DO RUN THE RISK OF
THOSE PROBLEMS OCCURRING AND I
THINK A.
YOU KNOW WE AGREE WITH THAT ON
SOME LEVEL.
.
JUST TO CONTINUE AND YOU HAVE.
THIS CHAIR CALLED ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT SORT OF THE ISSUE
WITH ON GOING THAT OUR DEBT
SERVICE RATIO RIGHT NOW
DOMINATES THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S PAID OUT A GENERAL FUND
SOLELY TO PAY OFF BOND THAT. IS
ABOUT FIVE PERCENT AND IT CAN BE
DEBATED WHETHER OR NOT THAT
NUMBER IS TOO HIGH OR TOO LOW.
AND THERE'S EVEN DEBATES ABOUT
THAT YOU KNOW IN MY OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT. BUT I THINK THE FACT
REMAINS IN THE QUESTION WE NEED
TO ASK IS THERE'S NO PRIORITY OF
BOND AT.
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE WALL A DAT ANY
ISSUES WITH THAT IN THE STATE
AND YOU KNOW AS HE TERMS OUT I
THINK WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEE A
PULLBACK FROM THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE PROP FIFTY ONE. ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND NINE BILLION DOLLARS
SCHOOL BOND.
THERE'S A CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
BOND ON THIS BALLOT IN ADDITION
TO THE WATER BOND.
AND.
.
AND I THINK BEG THE QUESTION OF
PRIORITIZING THIS DEBT GOING
FORWARD IS REALLY IMPORTANT WE
HAVEN'T DONE THAT. FOR EXAMPLE
IS WATER MORE IMPORTANT HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF QUESTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO ASK THAT I DON'T
THINK WE'RE ADDRESSING.
AND THERE IS AN APPROPRIATE USE
I THINK OF EXPENDITURES IN A
WATER BOND I THINK.
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER ASPECTS
BOTH OF THIS BOND AS WELL AS
PROP SIXTY EIGHT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW TODAY COULD YOU LACK ACCESS
TO CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
AND THAT IS IMPORTANT AND YOU
KNOW BOND FUNDS SHOULD BE USED
AND YOU KNOW WHERE CERTAINLY IN
AGREEMENT WITH AWKWARDNESS TALK
ON THAT PLANE. BOND FUNDS SHOULD
BE USED TO HELP PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER THAT'S A VERY
SMALL PROPORTION OF THIS BUDGET
OF THIS BOND.
AND.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT PRIORITIZATION OF
BUYING THAT. AND MEMBERS FINALLY
THE YEAH.
.
THE OTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE.
IS.
THE ASPECT OF MONEY FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WATER PROJECT.
THAT'S NEARLY TEN PERCENT OF
THIS BOND AND I THINK THE
QUESTION THAT SHOULD BE AUSTIN
AND POSED.
YOU KNOW MUCH OF MISTER
GALLAGHER KIND OF DEAD. IS IS
THIS MATTER OF STATEWIDE CONCERN
AND SHOULD BE FUNDED BY STATE
BOND OR DIRECTLY BY.
WATER AGENCY REPAIRS WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE PROPOSAL.
YOU KNOW AGAN FARMERS AND
INDIVIDUALS DOWN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
YOU KNOW SHOULD PROBABLY BE
TARGETED TO PAY FOR THAT MORE
THAN STATE TAXPAYERS GENERALLY.
AND MINISTER GALLAGHER BROUGHT
THAT UP WITH THE OROVILLE DAM
AND I THINK THAT SAME THING WITH
ROUGHLY PI. TO YUBA IN OF
CENTRAL VALLEY WATER PROJECT AS
WELL.
SO AND THERE'S A FEW THOUGHTS
THAT WE HAVE A BE HAPPENING TEN
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS.
OR.
AND NO QUESTIONS APPRECIATE THAT
BOTH OF YOU FOR COMING BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AND SHARING YOUR
PERSPECTIVES ON THIS INITIATIVE.
ON BEHALF OF UP YOU KNOW
CHAIRMAN PLUMAS WELL THANK YOU.
YEAH.
WE ARE AT THIS TIME WILL TAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENTS IF ANYONE WANTS
TO.
JUST MAKE STATEMENT. ON THE
RECORD ON THE INITIATIVE.
SEEN AND NO ONE AND I THINK YOU
CAN ALL OF YOU FOR JOINING US
FOR. THIS JOINT HEARING AT THIS
TIME WE WILL ADJOURN